I want you to stop dreaming and I want
you to just start doing small things the
thing with the big dream is it gives you
the motivation to want to do something
well I mean you don't really need
anything anymore you need your computer
that's all you need
rise and shine it's in spresso time good
morning believe nation it's evan my one
word is believe and i believe in you i
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that i want to see exploded onto the
world so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message just start over to you
Mel Robbins Vicky writes I'm trying to
become a fashion and beauty blogger and
Mert and earn money from it full-time
but I have some kind of mental block and
procrastination problem this is
something that we see over and over and
over again and it's this idea that you
don't ever start you stay trapped in
your head and if you feel paralyzed if
you've been spinning the same ideas over
and over and over again then you know
what I'm talking about you see many of
you are thinking way too [ __ ] big
you're attaching way too much pressure
on the things that you're interested in
until you start blogging about fashion
you won't even know if you like it so
thinking that you have a dream about
doing it and thinking that you have this
grand plan that you're gonna do it
full-time
it is a complete and utter waste of your
time to be dreaming that big and let me
tell you why because oftentimes if
you're the kind of person like Vicky
that's getting trapped up here the
bigness of what you're thinking about is
what's stopping you what I want you to
do if you're in Vicki's situation is I
want you to stop dreaming and I want you
to just start doing small things I want
you to go back to curiosity and
less into crushing your big goals you
think about life and business and
success is that you have to be willing
to start and for people that
procrastinate starting is the hardest
part for people that worry for people
that think too big starting is the
hardest part folks that study
procrastination talk about the fact that
the only way to beat procrastination is
to create what they call a starting
ritual which is a way to push yourself
to get started because all the research
shows that if we can push you to get
started on something you'll likely keep
going so I think it helps to have a big
dream and I think it's really important
that you get started right away the
thing with the big dream is it gives you
the motivation to want to do something
having a big goal of what you want to
accomplish right when you close your
eyes to think of that world that you
want to create can be motivating can be
inspiring for you if you don't have a
big dream a big vision often it can be
hard to get up and going in the morning
and so I think it's really great to have
a big dream the problem though is
sometimes that big dream is so big that
it's scary and that you feel I can't do
this alone how the money to do this I
don't have the resources I need to go
and raise capital so for whatever
business that you want to build there's
always a big version of it and it's
always a small version of it and so the
challenge that I have for you is I think
you should have a big dream but then
also figure out what's the most
immediate thing that I can do to make
progress today break it down into
bite-sized chunks and see today
Wednesday or Thursday whatever today is
when we're watching this what can I do
today to move a little bit closer on my
dream I see it happen so many so many so
many times entrepreneurs come and pitch
me they have an idea they want to raise
venture capital they want to raise angel
capital they have this huge vision for
what they want to do but to make it
happen they need to raise two million
dollars and because they feel in their
head that they can't do anything until
they raise two million dollars they
don't want to do the small stuff they
don't want to take little actions and so
they're off spending all their time
trying to raise two million box and
guess what that never happens they never
actually go off and take that big step
because that's not how companies are
built companies are not built giant
steps at a time they're built little
tiny steps at a time and they spend so
much time out there trying to raise
capital that there
never actually building their business
and so it's great to have that big
motivating dream and as soon as you get
an idea for something find some way to
test it out on a small scale immediately
today I look at my business as an
example
my big goal my big vision I want to
solve the world's biggest problem
untapped human potential it's a problem
that will never be solved it's a
lifelong ambition a lifelong goal for me
it will never be accomplished in my
lifetime maybe maybe in my son's a grand
granddaughters lifetime that's gonna
happen but in my lifetime it's not gonna
happen and I love that it's as big
driving impossible to reach a goal and
that drives me every day and how do I
solve it I'm here making videos for you
guys I'm responding to people on social
media I'm creating content to help you
write and so breaking it down to the
micro and so I have a big goal for what
I want to accomplish and then I have a
3-month goal for what I'm trying to do
in the short term if you look back five
years I would never have known that I
would be doing this I was doing YouTube
videos I wasn't taking it really
seriously I never thought that I wanted
to write a book I didn't think I needed
to have a book it wasn't in me I've
already written two books now and so I
think it's really hard to project out I
don't have a five-year goal as soon as I
get a five-year goal I find a way to
start making it happen immediately as
soon as you get a goal it's like I wish
I could do this in five years or ten
years then find a way to start right now
you don't have to wait for anything
would it be great if you had ten
thousand dollars actually to go and
spend on it now yes would it be great if
you could leave your job and go get it
right now yes but that's not the reality
situation so you have to find a way to
start taking immediate action right now
to move forward on it and so I have the
lifelong never gonna happen goal and I
have my three-month window and I have no
idea where I'm gonna be in one year in
two years five years whether it's
writing my books whether I've quit
YouTube because I don't like it anymore
whether I've moved on to something else
or whether I'm doubling down I've
doubled my team and I'm all-in on
YouTube to make it even better I think
that's really important so for you if
that big dream is inspiring to you then
I think it's great to have if
big dream is so scary and impossible and
it paralyzes you when you don't take any
action then figure out how do I take
some kind of immediate small action so
that instead of going here all I'm doing
is taking one step and every day taking
one step at a time
and you look back and realize that you
traveled a long distance now I've got a
special bonus clip for you but before
getting to that I want to know your
thoughts do you agree with me that
having a big vision can be motivating
and inspiring or are you in Mel's camp
where you feel like you shouldn't have a
big goal and only do the kind of the
small stuff and head of you to see if
that's gonna be a fit for you long term
or not I'm really curious to hear your
thoughts leave it down in the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso and enjoy the bonus
[Music]
when you Instagram you posted about
writing music in the hotel room that is
totally 100% you I would get
instrumentals from songs that already
existed so I have these demos where you
hear like the music is from like born to
die by Lana Del Rey and I wrote like a
whole other song labyrinth world and
that's how I basically started to
develop my voice as a songwriter when I
got into the studio to really for the
first time to work on this album which
was January everybody was kind of they
came in with his eyes would look like oh
I have an idea for you like play it for
me and I was like let's do something
from scratch and they were like oh you
actually write like you actually have a
point of view you actually have
something that you want to talk about
today like I'm so happy that I that I
started writing those like demos on the
road because if it weren't for that I
wouldn't have even had the confidence to
be like oh I I want to do this today
guys and as opposed to just taking
something but I wouldn't have even know
where to start
graduated from Stanford studied African
American Studies and political science
was heavy into directing and producing
plays at school and then I created my
first web series my senior year
eventually moved back to LA and just
started doing all these odd jobs and
trying to establish myself as a
videographer or an editor and trying to
get worked that way and hopefully by
like in my mind my filming weddings and
filming you know talents high school
talent shows I'd be discovered by a film
director who'd be like wow you really
filmed that wedding nicely but that
wasn't the case Jay oh my god that issue
wow I haven't seen you since college why
this is where people who major in
african-american studies end up sweetie
I'd started a black film blog I was
super into film I still am the same
types of black movies were coming out
with the same types of type of humor and
it was frustrating and I was voicing man
on my blog and I remember one comment
like you complain so much why don't you
make something and that like like oh
well okay I will how was the game
changed with technology in music well I
mean you don't really need anything
anymore
you need your computer that's all you
need you don't need any any keyboards
you don't need anything to produce
interviews if you know the program like
good quality music you know and then
obviously you're gonna have to you know
you have to know melodies and you know
at not everyone can learn that but it's
definitely made it easier for so many
people to get into this and you know get
started with it and and you know a lot
of people maybe that before couldn't
afford then wanna risk buying hardware
for in you know thousands of dollars
because they didn't know if they could
produce or not but now it's like all
through pretty much nothing you can just
download it's amazing things like
GarageBand for example exactly yeah or
any of the proto so many programs and
you know it's all about how you work
with the program as well so no it's it's
just amazing how how easy it is to get
started
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core values is that we believe that
people with passion and not one drop of
my self-worth depends on your acceptance
of me I don't ever give up I'd have to
be dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten Rose a success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details